[Musique]
il est 8h30
tous les élèves de l'école pierre
d'iberville à longueuil sont déjà à
l'intérieur
tous sauf la classe de 4e de madame
claude charbonneau commencez-vous
revanche ou parce que chaque matin quand
temps le permet les élèves de l'amt
charbonneau font 20 minutes de marche ou
de course avant d'entrer en classe
il m'a fait ça leur permet vraiment de
se détendre que pour certains de se
défouler physiquement si bien je faisais
moi j'aime ça courir le matin parce
qu'elle est choquée s'est concentrée
appris en classe quand les enfants
arrivent ex tu es fatigué le matin faut
faire plus de gestion de classe sont
plus énervés sont plus que c'était le
moment le temps que ça prend pour
arriver à les calmer pour commencer à
enseigner mais c'est le temps que moi je
prends à l'extérieur et havrais d'avoir
courir et marcher deux de l'énergie tu
peux mieux travailler si je cours
baissent après je serai mieux évidemment
c'est pas tout le monde qui comprennent
c'est il y en a qui disent que je perds
mon temps avec les odeurs mais vous
pouvez même où je vois les bienfaits ça
fait des années que je fais ça nous
voilà maintenant à montréal nord à
l'école primaire pierre de coubertin au
niveau de l'organisation scolaire la
locomotive c'est l'épreuve des jetta
depuis 1984 depuis 35 ans les élèves de
pierre de coubertin endroit chaque jour
à une heure d'éducation physique
en fait ici le tiers du temps passé à
l'école est dédié au sport ses papiers
c'est chaque séquence d'enseignement
véhicule une valeur d'un des jeux
collective à la valeur que véhicule
c'est l'esprit sportif une école il est
tjrs esclatine
moi je convaincu profondément convaincu
que ça s'adresse à monsieur madame tout
le monde
on n'a pas besoin de des reds qui
excelle pour faire partie de ce projet
bien en contre et on va travailler pour
faire pour faire réussir ses élèves love
horizontales verticales en classe on
retrouve des élèves plus concentrés plus
disciplinés les faits qui bouge un peu
plus le sas a permis de mieux se
concentrer sans garde permet de nous
apprendre vidre taxer toutes les
stratégies à mettre en place le mans
pour permettre l'apprentissage et le
défi cassions physique signifie moins
d'heures passées en classe mais pas
nécessairement de moins bonnes notes
bon nombre d'enfants vont même avoir de
meilleurs résultats particulièrement en
mathématiques la recherche qui est faite
récemment grand neuroscience montrent
que justement l'activité physique
améliore les mécanismes de
l'apprentissage
le professeur trudeau rappelle que dans
les années 70 on a testé une heure
d'éducation physique par jour sur des
élèves de trois rivières ils ont obtenu
les résultats à peu près équivalent dans
toutes les matières et ils ont augmenté
les résultats en mathématiques
est ce qu'on a observé c'est que les
femmes qui avaient participé au
programme lorsqu'elle des étais aux
primaires est encore plus active que la
moyenne de la population québécoise
une heure d'éducation physique par jour
à l'école primaire va avoir des
répercussions jusque dans la trentaine
véronique marchand estime qu'il est
temps que le québec fasse plus de place
à l'éducation physique à l'école est
c'est une question de volonté de courage
politique de ce débat nous la santé des
jeunes le besoin de nos enfants de se
développer de façon matrix pour nous
c'est une priorité qui ont fait ce qu'il
faut pour la mettre en place
le retour à longueuil les élèves de
madame charbonneau ont terminé leur
marche du matin je les vois les
bénéfices parce que j'ai ainsi tout le
monde de faire pareil parce que c'est
gratuit
oui c'est son hot 100 classement récup à
l'ingestion vienne oxygénée c'est dans
le calme et le silence que les élèves
prennent pour une journée en classe
[Musique]